good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I
recently discovered this box full of
childhood memorabilia it hasn't been
explored in at least 10 years and today
we're gonna find out what's inside the
first thing I noticed when I opened the
box is this participant badge to a
science and engineering fair I didn't
finish first I didn't finish second or
third but I did participate thank the
fact that mom and dad chose to keep my
participant ribbon perhaps indicates why
you're the brother who deconstructed an
adding machine here we have a mom and
dad why did you ever let me buy these
glasses picture photograph of me from my
brief experimentation with contact
lenses and a picture of me from back
when I was the worst player in my
childhood soccer team all right what
else oh heck look academic decathlon
medals I think it looks like the rest of
this box contains boxes when I was a kid
I had a box collection and by when I was
a kid I mean until my early 20s anyway
let's see if the boxes have anything in
them this is a lovely box given to me by
my college girlfriend it's empty that's
a metaphor this one's a winner oh and
there's stuff inside but sadly it's just
more boxes empty box another empty box
what childhood memories did you preserve
John
oh I preserved memories of emptiness
this box actually has something in it it
is a rose given to me by Betsy Hinkle my
10th grade homecoming dance date oh my
god there's also a tooth in there it's
one of my baby teeth anchor at any rate
someone's baby teeth this box had some
of my old Cub Scout patches in it from
1985 this box had a stamp from Germany
inside of it God I chose to keep that
this one's empty this one I can't figure
out how to open that's kind of exciting
yeah wow it's empty this box just does a
bunch of pennies in it I don't know why
I chose to keep them you shouldn't even
exist pennies I know what you're
wondering Hank what's in this box you'll
never guess unless you guess boxes
alright Hank last box my most beloved
box from childhood this real cigar box
let's see what's inside
oh there's pictures there's actually
something of value in here these are not
pictures of me these are mostly pictures
of flowers flower flower no oh there's
me what am i doing am i eating a snake
that's the one Hank that's the one
picture of me I
chose to keep Hank down at the bottom
beneath all of the boxes was this
beautiful book baby's milestones birth
to seven years filled out by our mom and
dad there's like the little bracelet
that mom wore at the hospital Holroyd
pictures for me just after birth here my
footprints and here on this page hank
preserved for all time my mom and dad's
first words about me my mother said he's
ugly
exclamation point and my dad said he's
so purple exclamation point not to be
fair I've seen a few newborns in my day
and they do tend toward the ugly and the
purple so like what if we learned from
this trip down memory lane
two things I think first put things in
your boxes and secondly life is not so
much about things as it is about people
and what we do together Hank the amazing
thing about that box of childhood
memories is that you could go through
the whole thing without ever knowing I
had a brother and yet nonetheless it is
completely impossible for me to imagine
my life without you you adding machine
deconstructing nerd Hank I'll see you on
Friday